[Applause]
all right y'all welcome to morning
coffee thoughts it's the first time I've
done one of these in the morning in a
long time because
all right
I've decided
I am going to make myself start getting
up before 10. Oh I know
you guys are like Pearl the average
person gets up before 10.
well I've been doing these late shows
for a while and because there's like
people over here
because there's people over all the time
I I just I'm up late and it's not good
it's not good I don't like the way I
feel and I was like you know what
I don't have the discipline to go to bed
early but if I keep getting up before 10
I'm gonna get so tired that I'm just
gonna start falling asleep so I will be
up
I only slept like five hours last night
but I'm like I'm getting up I am getting
up early okay
So Yesterday guys
I had to kick a crazy lady off my show
I'm so tired of these crazy ladies guys
oh I'm so tired so we recently made a
small switch to having all female panels
now I want to bring back the men but the
problem was we just had so many guys
coming on that we're trying to
and we didn't do a good job logging all
of our guests from the past so we're
just trying to build a database of women
and then we're going to bring back some
met because it's really easy for us to
get men on the panel it's harder to get
women
so I want to talk about fresh infant
okay
nothing
bad okay
when I first watched their stuff I
thought Myron was a bit aggressive I was
like why is he so angry and like why is
he so like
like any type of girl would say
something he's like that would be like
why
let me tell you guys after a year
hats I'm sorry if I can't talk
hats off to him because
I didn't realize how hard it is to
control a room right and that's probably
I think my weakness as a host like
keeping everybody in line
having them not over talk The Host
Etc and recently this week I got some
some pushback okay you know the pushback
was
are my followers Pearl has a rule not to
over talk the host no wonder nobody
pushes back
guys guys
one I'm very lenient with that rule
let's let's be honest usually if I've
kicked someone out
they've done it at least three or four
times the whole podcast I'm quite I'm
quite a patient person
okay
I'm quite a patient person so
you know I'll give you I'm not just
gonna kick you out right away okay but
here's the thing
women they will be so wrong they will
die on their Hill guys
that's why Myron is so strict with his
rules that's why it seems like he's a
bit aggressive it's because girls are
crazy and it doesn't even matter if
they're a hundred percent in the wrong
they will still convince themselves the
right so last week last week
or whatever whatever it was a couple
weeks ago
Esther made a video talking about me
again
I'm excited to react to this one all
right I'm I'm excited for it all right
they her it's funny I have a whole
London hate group here and them and
their followers are so obsessed with me
that every Coffee Talk someone watches
it gets sent out and then they're like
oh this is what's happening with pearl
okay all right
anyways
um it was so funny because she tried
she cried to get this person that you
that used to work for me right but we it
was like an amicable just didn't you
know and get him to say like bad stuff
about me and he was just like no you're
right it's so funny this girl's so
delusional she went off to Destiny tried
with that went off to this dude chat
with that it's like I think she must be
crazy because there's so many people
that'll tell her she's wrong
no
last night I kicked off another girl
off the podcast okay
another girl now
I really didn't want to kick her off I
really didn't want to kick her off to be
honest like
but I was reading the super chats and
before the show we read the rules of the
show okay this girl we read before the
show to wait till I'm done with the
super chats so
I read that I was reading the super
chats and she kept interrupting kept
interrupting
this is last episode if you guys want to
watch it now
Pearl Pearl
I gave her a warning and then she kept
arguing with me and then she just
started to get rooted sorry my alarm
went off then this girl started to get
rude and disrespectful okay
so what does Pearl do
what does Pearl do
I say no you're being rude get off get
off okay
she sent me a voice note this morning I
haven't listened to it yet okay well I
lied I was new a little
think she's gonna take accountability
or is she going to blame me
is she gonna blame me
that's
take a poll in the chat take a poll in
the chat okay let's go
yeah
you have a question
top 10 people with strong personality at
the end of the day yes I interrupted you
but you couldn't easily let that into a
discussion that's what a good podcast
would do yes I interrupted you
but run the podcast
the way I want you to run the podcast
it's like the like the entitlement of
these crazy ladies they think oh my God
it's like why would I take advice from
idiots
let me let me get this straight I'm
shooting at 4K I have a million
subscriber podcasts I do the recruiting
but let me come to you for advice
God these goddamn women are delusional
okay
okay you have the worst attitude ever
you're [__] grumpy and listen none of
the girls that even enjoy themselves
there's bloody [__] dead
you know what's funny
that's part one she sent me like four
voice notes those girls had so much fun
they they're coming back today we're
doing a dating video with the network so
they're gonna be on this dating show
yeah and apparently this girl like
walked in like she was hot [__] guys I
don't know who you are
I'm like uh
and she was like so proud of all the oh
my gosh hold on
video
you're not gonna [__] phone I don't
know what the [__] is wrong with you
saying oh like oh who the [__]
like that people that want you to go
I can tell you exactly who speaks like
that people that want you to go now I
will give her one thing
yesterday I
guys I have had so much going on lately
I haven't been able to put as much into
the shows as I would like to because
I've had to fix recruiting
and there's just a lot of [__] with
management that I hate that I absolutely
hated and I'm miserable with
and
I know if I just work
I figure this out in the next like month
or two it's gonna be fine
but right now it's just we're in Growing
Pains where we're building the system so
we just built out a new studio
um I had to
let go an employee that worked here that
spend a lot of money on my CR um
not gonna get into it there's just been
a lot going on so maybe you know
again the hard thing is like when girls
come on and they think they're hot [__]
and I'm like ladies I I don't know who
you are I can't treat everybody like
they're special I'm sorry I'm sorry and
this girl I just you know I can handle
strong personalities I've had so many
people on the show that are strong but
when you're crazy I can't help you
now let's see
why does she let's see 82 000 followers
does she even have a YouTube channel
she's got something on Spotify
like I don't know who this is
oh my God I thought she was famous she
was 210 subscribers on YouTube
yeah I definitely okay but let's let's
finish this let's finish this some UK
artist
s
you right now I've got bad courses to
take the whole [__] career Dash the
[__] up
you have Bearcat what does that even
mean
you have bare contacts
okay all right
it's like well if you did that I could
have made money off the clips it's like
these ladies don't know
all right
hey now why did you call me here then so
I'm trying to say you're the one you and
your stupid guy call me here to follow
the rules of the podcast it's like this
is what you could do with modern women
you could lay out these are the rules if
you don't follow the rules security is
there all right
people
Pokemon at the end of the day like why
did you call me at the end of the day
like again that's perfect part three
lady lady
I promise you I don't need you to come
back I promise to God like these women
act like I need them and that's the
funny uh
okay go go expose me all right
to [__] with
is that a threat
what does draw you out mean
draw you out
huh
anyways
she'll probably join the London hate
group of these crazy women
you know
uh
sorry for judging you Myron because I
don't know how
how I'm actually I'm gonna mute this
ladies I don't have to look at her
messages
I thought maybe she sent me an apology
nope
mute
yeah
anyways
um
it's just crazy it's like women with no
business experience that only have a
career of unsuccessfulness want me to
come what
what want
me to come to them for it's just funny
honestly and guys I'm not trying to be
cocky right there's a lot of people I
would take advice from people better
than me all right there's a lot of
people I look up to in the space
um that I think have really good ideas
and I look up to them okay
but it's like women are so delusional
that's crazy and it's the same thing
with women I heard 54 of women think
they can do their boss's job actually I
gotta go to the gym better than them
I was just thinking about this I'm like
I would believe it because these women
have never run a podcast have no clout
or experience and think they could run a
podcast better than me okay it's like
I'm not trying to brag all right I'm
really not but I'm 26 years old
I built this following in a year you can
hate on me all you want but I did
something right okay and a lot of people
lately now I'm not gonna name names but
a lot of people in this space
say that I have you know
my subs don't count basically
because I got a lot of them from shorts
fine fine
but numbers don't lie I got 60 million
views this month
um
you know
I'm just gonna leave it at that I'm just
gonna leave it at that
women are delusional
um this is why I was thinking I was like
this is why women
like Horrible Bosses okay and I'm gonna
say this as a woman that hates being a
boss I cannot wait until I can afford a
CEO oh my God Jesus Christ someone else
to deal with these problems oh that is
my plan long term guys
and every day the women just convinced
me more and more
and the funny thing is
it's like
if she didn't act like that
I probably was good I was gonna put her
on a dating show to be honest
I just need you to fall follow rules of
a podcast that's it and so it's funny a
lot of these women [__] up future
opportunities not even on my show I have
two signed talents
and we work with some of the biggest
people in the UK like we have [__] lined
up all right
yeah okay
and
all these men the contacts are just
trying to sleep with you
they all know they can see you crazy
at least I'll tell you anyways guys
um these women are wearing me down
oh my gosh I'm tired I think I'm gonna
bring back a couple guys on the show
we're just trying to build up the women
right now
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell okay I love you guys
bye